Why am I telling you this?
Well,
what the children were doing,
you think about how the tail,
did the children come up
with these weird ideas,
you know,
I mean,
first of all we should note the children
are not stupid and they can also dream
up the most horrible things,
you know,
um,
because they have an imagination that's
capable of extending itself out into the
terrifying.
Now everyone knows that because all you
have to do is remember when you were a
kid,
you know,
when you were hiding under the covers,
because there were horrible
things in your dark room.
You know,
you can populate the darkness
with monsters with no problem.
And you should be able to,
because there are
monsters in the darkness.
Even though your parents
might tell you there aren't,
it's like there might not be any dirt
monsters in that particular piece of
darkness.
And that's a perfectly reasonable
thing to tell your children.
But in the darkness as a whole,
it's like,
yeah,
look the hell out.
So the children aren't stupid now.
So then the,
the,
the adults start to question them and
the kids or the back of their brain,
the little imaginative part is thinking,
what are these people want?
What do these people want?
And so they'll throw him out a little
bit of information and they'll,
the adults will perk up.
They'll focus right on
that piece of information.
So maybe it's a cop who really
hates childs satanist abductors,
which you know,
is perfectly reasonable stance.
And so when the child offers
any information about,
about the existence of such a thing,
well the cop will perk up
and then the child thinks,
oh,
I see.
Well,
so sort of what's going on?
It seems to have something to do.
They don't think this consciously,
you know,
but their imagination is working.
How do I model the reality
that's been presented to me?
And that's when the dream
start to kick in too.